Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vous demande toute votre authenticité,
votre sincérité.
Pas de filtre.
Fermez les yeux, concentrez-vous,
et si vous ressentez la moindre
petite peur - ne fermez pas les yeux -
quand je vais dire un mot, levez-la main.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Uberisation !
Hou la la, il y en a des mains levées !
Ça va sucrer nos emplois !
L'ubérisation, c'est comme les robots,
ça va nous transformer en Matrix !
C'est honteux de faire travailler
des gens 70 heures par semaine !
Mais oui, c'est clair !
C'est vrai, ça fait peur !
Mais moi, je suis intimement convaincu
que l'ubérisation est peut-être,
sous certains aspects,
une vraie opportunité
vers un monde de paix.
Je vais vous expliquer
L'étincelle s'est produite un jour où
je sortais d'un rendez-vous bien stressé.
Je suis monté dans un VTC
et là, j'arrive, Slimane, bel homme,
beau gars, belle barbe, tout sourire,
m'ouvre la porte, m'invite
à rentrer dans son taxi nickel,
me donne une bouteille d'eau,
me dit de ne pas m'inquiéter,
et là, mon stress tombe.
J'ai envie de lui sourire.
Mon regard sur lui change
et il commence à m'expliquer sa vie.
Comment ce job de taxi
a changé son existence.
Lui à qui il n'avait jamais été donné
l'opportunité d'avoir un job avant.
Lui qui travaille 60 heures par jour,
(le mec qui bosse 60 heures par jour...
par semaine)
(Rires)
Il y en a qui suivent !
Et il a le sens du service.
Et Slimane,
il a une reconnaissance pour ça.
Le fait de lui avoir donné
une opportunité de bosser.
Maintenant, il a envie
d'être reconnaissant envers les autres
et ça se sent
quand on est dans sa voiture.
Après avoir passé dix ans aux États-Unis,
monté et revendu plusieurs sociétés
de technologie d'internet,
à 40 ans, j'ai revendu ma dernière
entreprise, je suis rentré en Europe,
j'ai quitté San Francisco,
je suis revenu en Europe,
et je me suis rappelé
de cette petite étincelle, en me disant,
si ce Slimane arrive à changer
le regard des gens dans sa voiture,
à travers une expérience de VTC,
et si on faisait la même chose,
mais pour tout l'emploi ?
Si on arrivait
à ubériser tout l'emploi ?
Est-ce que ça ne serait pas un moyen
d'arriver à redonner à chacun
la chance de trouver un job
et peut-être de connaître plus de monde ?
Mais je voudrais faire
une petite mise au point.
Qu'est-ce que l'ubérisation ?
Ça sonne souvent
avec précarisation, évasion fiscale,
esclavagisme moderne !
C'est des termes qu'on entend souvent.
Moi, je pense que comme tout changement
de paradigme économique,
on l'a vu dans les années 30,
la révolution industrielle,
il faut une régulation
et bien souvent les États
sont longs à légiférer
et mettent du temps pour arriver
à suivre les révolutions industrielles.
Là nous assistons à une véritable
révolution industrielle
et ça va prendre un petit peu de temps.
Mais je vais revenir
sur ces trois concepts, précarisation.
Certes, ces emplois
ne sont pas des emplois en CDI.
Mais savez-vous que les vétécistes
en France, depuis cinq ans,
ont créé 10 000 emplois,
10 000 personnes au boulot,
et il faut savoir que parmi
ces 10 000 personnes,
il y en a plus de 80 %
qui n'avaient aucun job avant,
c'est leur premier job,
et l'autre majorité pour qui
c'est un deuxième job.
Est-ce qu'on parle
vraiment de précarisation ?
Sachant que dans le même temps,
je ne crois pas
qu'un seul des taxis français
ait été mis au chômage,
en tout cas pas 10 000
dans les 5 dernières années.
On n'est pas en train de détruire
des emplois pour en créer d'autres,
de précariser des emplois,
on est juste en train
de créer de nouvelles opportunités
pour des personnes
qui n'avaient jamais eu accès.
Évasion fiscale : c'est pareil, je pense
que les choses vont se réguler
Oui il y a des abus, c'est certain.
Je vais vous prendre
l'exemple de cette plateforme
de location saisonnière immobilière,
qui jusqu'à très récemment,
ne collectait pas les taxes d'habitation.
Le gouvernement leur a demandé
de régulariser, après quelques années,
et maintenant ils collectent au nom
de l’État les taxes d'habitation.
Ça se régule.
C'est pas que ces sociétés soient là
pour casser les codes fiscaux,
c'est que pour aller vite,
compte tenu du temps que
les États mettent à légiférer,
ils sont en avance,
mais systématiquement,
derrière, ils régularisent.
N'ayons pas peur de cela.
Troisième point : l'esclavagisme moderne.
Là encore, soyons prudents.
Il faut tout de même savoir que
dans les années 30,
les ouvriers se sont réunis en syndicats
pour combattre et être plus forts
face aux grands industriels ;
il se passe exactement la même chose !
L'ensemble des prestataires vétécistes
ou d'une plateforme qui ubérise
la location immobilière
se réunissent régulièrement.
Encore récemment,
on a eu des exemples à Paris
de chauffeurs qui se réunissent ensemble,
ils créent une sorte de syndicat 2.0,
et qui arrivent à faire pression
pour arriver à soit diminuer
leurs horaires,
soit augmenter leurs salaires.
Donc ça s'organise aussi.
Ce que je veux dire par ici,
c'est que précarisation, évasion fiscale,
et esclavagisme,
oui, c'est sûr, on peut voir ça comme ça.
Mais si on essaye de regarder
toutes les bonnes choses
qui se passent par ailleurs,
et la régulation qui arrive,
ce n'est pas si grave que ça.
Ce à quoi je voudrais
m’intéresser maintenant,
c'est la bonne partie de l'ubérisation.
L'ubérisation, c'est donner à chacun,
quel que soit son âge
quelle que soit sa profession,
quelle que soit son expérience,
quelle que soit son origine,
la capacité à pouvoir créer son propre job
sans forcément avoir de diplôme.
Je vous donne un exemple :
J'ai mon permis de conduire,
je suis dynamique,
j'ai un peu de temps
et je n'ai pas de job.
Je peux prendre du jour au lendemain
un job de taxi.
Un autre exemple :
je suis bien né, j'ai de l'argent,
j'habite à New York,
j'ai un appartement disponible,
inoccupé, je peux le louer.
Mais également, je suis un pauvre gars
sur les bords du Nil,
qui a juste un accès internet,
et pareillement, je peux,
grâce à ces plateformes,
mettre à disposition
la location de ma petite cabane
à un touriste japonais,
probablement au même tarif,
voire plus cher
que l'appartement de New York,
alors qu'avant, c'était juste impossible.
Mieux encore :
je suis un designer, super talentueux.
J'habite dans un slum, un bidonville,
à New Delhi.
J'ai une connexion internet
au cybercafé à côté de chez moi.
Je peux désormais proposer mes services
au même prix que n'importe
quel designer international
à des sociétés européennes
ou américaines.
N'est-ce pas une vraie opportunité, ça,
de donner à chacun, où qu'il soit,
la possibilité de pouvoir trouver un job,
et à travers l'insertion dans le travail,
une véritable existence sociale ?
Parce qu'il faut savoir que
ce n'est pas uniquement
pour ce genre de service,
mais on peut également être coiffeur,
être prof, conseiller fiscal, comptable,
bricoleur, dépanneur, et même médecin,
grâce à ce genre de plateforme.
Jusqu'ici, il fallait un diplôme,
imaginez-vous pour monter un salon
de coiffure, il faut un CAP de coiffure.
En revanche, avec une plateforme
ubérisant la coiffure, on le peut.
De la même manière, je reprends
l'exemple du taxi, aujourd'hui,
il faut quand même
débourser 50 000 à 200 000 euros
pour acheter votre plaque.
Alors évidemment,
si vous voulez,
d'un côté, soit il faut avoir de l'argent
et beaucoup d'énergie
pour arriver à créer son propre business
dans le monde traditionnel,
soit il faut « se résigner »
à essayer de trouver un job.
Et là, dans beaucoup de pays,
notamment la France,
pour trouver un job,
il vaut mieux être bien né,
de la bonne couleur,
venir du bon endroit,
et avoir un peu de piston.
Et c'est ça, l'ubérisation.
Quel que soit votre âge,
quelle que soit votre origine,
quel que soit votre lieu de naissance,
quelle que soit votre couleur de peau,
quelle que soit la beauté de votre visage,
moche, beau,
quelle que soit votre religion,
vous avez la même opportunité
de pouvoir travailler à distance
et avoir un job.
Comment ça marche ?
En fait, ça marche essentiellement
à la confiance.
La particularité de ces plateformes,
c'est qu'elles créent
un environnement de confiance,
à travers trois outils essentiellement :
le premier, c'est la recommandation ;
le deuxième,
c'est la certitude d'être payé,
un environnement « safe »,
« secure », de paiement.
Et le troisième,
c'est la progression personnelle.
Je vais revenir sur la recommandation.
Sur toutes ces plateformes,
les prestataires sont souvent
recommandés par d'autres personnes.
Au fil de l'eau, chacun des prestataires
va bâtir sa propre réputation,
va étendre son réseau
et va de lui-même
arriver à bâtir
un environnement de confiance
de personnes qui lui ont fait confiance.
Donc plus il avance,
plus il donne de la confiance
à travers le réseau.
La certitude d'être payé :
toutes ces plateformes
ont des solutions de paiement sécurisé
avec des solutions de remboursement
si ça ne fonctionne pas,
et figurez-vous que je discute souvent
avec les taxis
qui ne sont pas des taxis vétécistes,
ubérisés, des taxis à l'ancienne,
et une des raisons pour lesquelles souvent
ils ne sont pas toujours très agréables,
c'est qu'ils ont la trouille
que le client se barre sans payer.
Effectivement entre le cas de figure
où vous êtes dans une voiture
dans laquelle la solution est sécurisée,
la personne a été recommandée,
on sait qu'elle a été checkée,
cinq étoiles à la fin,
la transaction sera payée,
il conduit, le gars peut partir,
de toute façon, il sera payé.
L'autre solution, on ne sait pas
à qui on a affaire,
on monte dans une voiture,
ça sent bon ou pas,
le gars ne sait pas s'il va être payé,
il a la trouille que le client parte,
c'est plus tendu.
Et la progression :
la progression,
c'est le plus important.
C'est plus pour votre employeur
que vous bossez, c'est pour vous.
C'est plus dynamique,
c'est votre propre progression
que vous maîtrisez.
Plus vous travaillez, plus ça vous
renvoie, plus ça étend votre réseau.
Et ça, c'est primordial.
C'est ça qui est révolutionnaire,
c'est que désormais,
vous prenez votre vie en main
et vous travaillez non plus
pour un employeur
mais pour créer
votre propre progression personnelle.
Chaque investissement
que vous mettez dans votre travail,
ça développe votre réseau.
Et ça, je pense que c'est
vraiment révolutionnaire.
Alors, certes, j'ai été un peu provocateur
parce qu'effectivement,
ce n'est pas si simple.
L'ubérisation fait
les titres des journaux,
il y a des grèves,
il y a des gens qui sont bloqués,
mais ce que je voulais illustrer ici,
c'est, en revenant
sur mon expérience avec Slimane,
Slimane que je n'aurais jamais eu
l'occasion de rencontrer,
parce que Slimane habite dans les cités
comme 90% de ces chauffeurs VTC,
il a une barbe,
je suis imberbe,
j'ai laissé un peu pousser les poils,
mais ça me fout la trouille,
les gars qui ont des barbes
dans les cités,
je l'aurais jamais rencontré ;
et pourtant, Slimane,
il m'a offert une opportunité unique :
pendant vingt minutes,
on est resté dans un huis clos,
on a parlé, on était en confiance.
Je suis sorti de là en me disant :
« Il est génial, ce gars. »
J'ai eu envie d'aller
rencontrer ses potes,
et je suis sorti de là,
la première chose que j'ai faite,
j'en ai parlé à d'autres personnes :
« Regarde, ça a changé mon regard
sur ce qu'il se passe dans les cités,
sur cette espèce de...
d'amalgame qu'on peut lire dans les médias
sur ce qu'il se passe dans les cités.
Et je pense que c'est
peut-être ça aussi, l'ubérisation :
la capacité à faire rencontrer
des personnes qui n'avaient jamais
l'occasion de se croiser
dans un vase clos, de confiance,
dans un environnement
qui leur permet d'interagir,
de mieux se connaitre,
sécurisé, et d'échanger.
Je ne suis pas tombé amoureux de Slimane
en sortant de la voiture,
mais je l'ai bien aimé.
Est-ce que c'est pas ça
le début de la paix ?
Commencer à s'aimer les uns les autres ?
Oui, je vais être un peu provocateur,
mais je pense que l'ubérisation
et ces plateformes,
si elles ont bien maîtrisées,
dans un cadre de confiance,
ça peut véritablement être
un chemin vers la paix.
(Applaudissements)